شهدت المدينه المنوره وعدد من المحافظات
التابعه لها طول امطار غزيره غير مسبوقه
تسببت في السيول وامتلات المنصات
بفيديوهات لما شهد السيول اخترنا البعض
منها
[موسيقى]
ومن بين الفيديوهات
صعبه بتوثق الانقاذ مجموعه من الشبان
للطفل كان عالق في منتصف السيول واستطاعوا
انهم ينقضوا من الغرقانه
الينا عب الهاتف من المدينه المنوره
العريف مازن الجهني الذي انقذ الطفل من
السيول اهلا بك
خبرنا عن لحظه انقاذ الطفل وعمليه انقاذ
الطفل
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم والصلاه والسلام
على سيدنا محمد عليه افضل الصلاه والسلام
الوادي
تعالوا شوف
وتوكلت على الله ولا اراديا غير انا واقف
عند الوادي
شفت اللهم صل على محمد ام الطفل في الجهه
الثانيه تنادي على ولدها
وتبكي
وولدها بنص المويه ولحد قادر ينزل له
وانا الحمد لله السباحه
وامها ملاقات
اما بحمد الله نزول للوادي
والحمد لله على كل حال
هذا بعود لكونك يعني كنت تعمل بالقطاع
الامني
الحرفيه كان يعني في حرفيه بالعمليه
الانقاذ
خبرنا على هذه بسبب خبرتك يعني بهالموضوع
بهذا المجال
والحمد لله الله سبحانه
قدرني على
توازني بواسطه مجرى الماء ومع مشي بالمويه
اني اتمسك لي بحاجه واطلع منها
توجه للطفل مباشره
[موسيقى]
وتقريبا
شرب من المويه حق الاجراء لانه جايب
تقريبا قبل مسافه يمشي مع المويه
مع الشيل
وفي
الحجر
السيلفي عليه وتمسك فيها
الحمد لله وقف بنفس الموقع الموضح
بالفيديوهات وانا جيت على نفس الموقع جيته
وتطمن فيه احد عنده
وهديته والحمد لله
اللهم لك الحمد
حاولت اني استرجع بالناس اللي حولنا
ينزلون انا اما حابب او ينزلوا لي شيء ااا
دفي فيها الطفل لين ما يجي اما الدفاع
المدني ولا
يجيها مختصه
اثناء السيول يعني والامطار الكثيفه اللي
شهدتها المدينه المنوره الفتره الاخيره
خاصه
الامطار ما شاء الله تبارك الله
ثلاث ايام
ماشي يعني كل الاوديه كلها شعبان وكل
[موسيقى]
المناجع المويه
والله عندنا احنا شخصين الشباب والامهات
الله يحفظهم
يا شباب نروح ندور الاوديه ونروح ندور
راسي
شكرا
جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]